So here's my little Evie scope set up on the patio.
You've got this lifelong love of astronomy.
I imagined you'd had many telescopes over the years.
You're going to set me straight here.
I have. So no I've never owned a telescope. When I was a kid,
my dad had a really nasty little cheap telescope that we messed around with for
a bit.
And I've got an old nautical telescope that just sort of lies around the place,
but I've never owned a serious look at the sky kind of telescope.
Why is that? Why is that? Why have you never had one?
Um, partly because,
so the times I've actually tried to set up telescopes myself.
It turns out I'm pretty hopeless at it. You know, if you go to an observatory,
there's a nice big telescope,
which somebody really competent a set up and controls and runs for you.
If it comes to trying to line up your own telescope and getting all the bits of
kit to work, that's not really something I'm particularly good at. Um,
so it it's never really appealed all that much until now.
What is the skill you lack or like,
what's the thing about you that made you not good at setting one up?
It is a strange thing. So years ago, uh,
I used to run field trips with undergraduates out to the Canary islands,
where there was a telescope that we used out there,
which is very basic telescope. And it was very interesting.
You could see amongst the students,
some of them just had this magic touch that they could just line the telescope
up pointing roughly where they wanted it to be.
And there would be the object they wanted to look at.
Whereas other people could be, you know,
really technically competent and try really hard and never get a decent image
out of it. And unfortunately I'm in the latter category.
All right. It's just like a, it's just like a knack. Is it like a magic touch?
It does. It, it is. Yeah. It really is a bit of a touch to it. Um,
and it's just not something I'm particularly good at.
Why has this changed professor? Why did you take the plunge because of the,
sort of the lockdown situation or no.
It was a complete coincidence. So actually a couple of years ago,
I back to Kickstarter, which is something I'd never done before. Um, but, uh,
there was this Kickstarter for basically someone was saying we're going to
produce a completely idiot proof telescope.
And so I figured that was just the thing for me. Um,
so I backed it really early and then it sort of disappeared for a while.
And I didn't actually think all that much more about it until I got a
notification saying, you know,
your telescopes being shipped and conveniently it arrived. Just,
this is a lockdown was beginning. So right at the beginning of a lockdown,
I got a nice telescope to play with.
So now you've been doing some lockdown astronomy.
I have. Yeah, not exactly from the ideal site in that it's sort of,
I can't go any further than my own back garden at the moment,
but I can take the telescope out there and stick it in the back garden and
pointed up at the sky, um, and start doing some astronomy.
The only slight snag I have here in my back garden is that the patches of
sky I can choose are somewhat limited because there are a lot of trees
and my wife wouldn't let me chop them down.
I know you've got a lot of trees around your house and you live in Nottingham,
which is, you know, a big city with lots of light,
but you can still get the job done Kenya.
Pretty much. Yeah, it is amazing. I mean this whole,
the whole point of this telescope is that it's actually designed to be used in
any environment.
And so actually what it does is it takes a whole series of really short
exposures, just keeps adding them up.
And some of the tests data that they did was, you know,
in really brightly lit places where you really couldn't see much of the sky at
all. And the amazing thing is if you just keep adding the data, you know,
the light from the stars and the galaxies is still there.
And eventually you can dig it out from the noise of all the city lights.
They actually did some tests in Las Vegas, for example,
which is not famous for its lack of lighting. Uh, and they were able to see,
you know, deep, deep sky objects from a parking lot in the middle of Las Vegas.
Now you're going to take us through some of your images that you've imaged from
your backyard in Nottingham, which I'm very excited about.
The obvious first one to look at is so-called first light.
Can you explain the term first light for people who aren't astronomers and what,
what that emotes.
It's, it's the man that magic moment and, you know, in my case, well,
actually I had a fair while to wait for this telescope,
but it is that magic moment where you've spent years and years building a
telescope will be in building an instrument and you finally get to point it at
the sky and see if it actually works. And so the first light image,
usually you pick something sort of reasonably dull and straightforward and
fairly bright,
just because you don't want to stress things too much at the outset.
And you want to find out what the problems might be with your setup. Um,
but yeah, that first light image,
when you first point the telescope at the sky and take a picture and hope you
hit something. And in this case I did.
What if, what, what did you choose for first light and why?
Okay, so messier 34,
very ordinary open cluster about a little over a thousand light years away,
a hundred million years old. So it's not a particularly exciting object. Um,
partly I wanted to pick it because it stars.
And actually one of the things you want to check with the telescope when you
first set it up is whether it's focused on art.
So you want to see how sharp point like the individual, uh, stars are.
And it really,
I picked it because actually this telescope is sufficiently smart.
That if you just say what's a good object to look at at the moment,
it'll tell you, um, and [inaudible] was what the telescope picked for me.
Okay. And you're happy with the picture.
It looks pretty good for a first first attempt. If you asked me.
It's pretty good. Yeah. It's a pretty sharp image. It's you know,
it wasn't quite in focus.
I've since figured out how to better how to focus the telescope,
but it's a nice, nice picture. You know, lots of stars there,
definitely a fluster and proves that it is amazing. Like this telescope,
you just basically, you take it out, you plunk it down on the ground.
The only thing you have to do is make sure it's level. But beyond that,
it basically figures everything out. So it,
it uses your phone to tell it where you are in the world.
So it knows roughly and what the time is. So it knows all that stuff,
but then you just pointed it in some random direction. It takes a picture.
It figures out from the pattern of stars as it sees,
what direction it was pointed in.
And at that point it will take you anywhere else in the sky.
And so part of this was just testing. Does that really work?
And it turns out it does you say go to MSCI eight 30, four and 10 seconds later.
There it is.
Is that taking away some of the pleasure or the skill to you,
like what's left to do, what's your role? Now.
I get to pick what I want to look at. As I said, it's the, you know,
the stuff that I'm really not very good at is that setting telescopes up,
making sure everything's aligned with everything else,
finding things in the sky, all that stuff has gone away now.
And I just get the pleasure of looking at things in the sky.
What have we got next? We've got comet C two Oh one nine one.
This was just something that was sort of timely in that it was a comment that
there was an announcement that there was, this comment had come along.
That potentially might be quite bright.
Subsequently it's actually turned out to be a bit of a bust in that it's fallen
to bits. So it's actually fragmented four apart. There was some hope.
This might be one of those bright comments you can see with the naked eye.
It's now not going to be. Um,
but there was quite a lot of interest in it at the time.
And it's an interesting target to go after because of course,
comments move relative to all the stars.
And so you actually have to find its current coordinates.
And instead of telling the telescope to go to a particular object,
you actually have to tell it which coordinates to go to.
So it was a good check to make sure that the telescope could actually pick up
things just on the basis of coordinates. And sure enough, there, it was one,
the telescope swung around to the coordinates that it had at the time.
That's pretty good. Any idea how far away that was at the time you mentioned it?
Like, are we talking like I didn't, I didn't even know where to start,
how close.
It's coming into the inner solar system at the moment.
So it'll be a matter of a few astronomical units. I would guess.
I honestly don't know.
It's all a bit was going to take it pretty close to the sun,
but I don't think it come that far yet.
So I think it sort of broke up on its way in.
If I can find out where it was on the night you imaged her,
I'll put a little thing on the screen for people at home in retrospect.
So they'll get no idea next on your list here. We have a
[inaudible], which I can, I can just make out in the image.
Yeah.
You might need to do a little bit of work on those images to actually get things
to a point where you can see them on the video. I guess it is pretty faint. Um,
so it's M 97.
Is this thing called the owl Nebula so-called cause I think maybe it was Hershel
was the first to observe it and found and drew this sketch of it,
which he sketched as a little owl for some reason,
but you can see quite why it's sort of it's this greenish circle with two dark
dots or two dark holes in it. Uh, it's a planetary Nebula.
So it's one of these late stages of a star, a bit like the sun,
which is in the process of blowing itself to bits.
So it's blown off all this outer layer.
So the big sort of round fuzzy thing or the outer layers of the star that had
been blown out already, uh, there's a white dwarf star in the middle.
You can maybe see the little bright dots of the white dwarf in the middle.
And then the two dark holes are actually where the star is now instead of just
blowing everything out symmetrically,
it's actually blowing things out along the poles of the star.
So it's evacuated to cavities. So those holes are actually, uh,
where it sort of tumbled through the material that it had previously objected
out. So it's quite a lot of structure going on there.
The green coloring blue-green coloring is partly down to scattered light from
the white dwarf, which is very hot in the middle, partly down to emission from,
uh, ionized oxygen cause INI.
So it's very hot and ionized oxygen produces this sort of characteristic green
shade. And then maybe you can see in the very outer parts, it turns red,
there's a sort of faint red ring around the outside.
That's where it's a bit cooler.
And you're seeing that characteristic red emission,
which comes from hydrogen gas.
Oh seven 97. There's also an excellent deep sky video. People can watch.
Absolutely. As are quite a few.
Of the things we're going to talk about.
I think the sun will become a planetary Nebula.
This could be how the sun could like in 5 billion years, time.
53 And NGC five Oh five, three.
Yes. Two for the price of one, two globular clusters,
actually very close to each other on the sky.
And actually both are very similar distances away.
They're two of the more distant ones in the Milky way,
but they're actually at similar distances and in a similar direction, in fact,
they're sufficiently close together.
They were even interacting with each other a little bit.
So there's some tidal interaction between the two that's been detected. Um,
so they really are sort of twins in that sense.
But the interesting thing about them is I've probably in one or two of my more
careless moments said when you've seen one globular cluster,
you've seen them all. Um,
the interesting thing about these two is they're about as different as you get
as globular clusters go. So, I mean,
one of them is impressively big and bright and the other is pretty pathetic.
Really. There are five times as many stars in the brighter one. Um,
but actually it looks a lot more impressive than even that factor of five
because it's very centrally concentrated.
So you get this real brightness in the middle. Um, whereas this,
the second one is it is a lot fainter, but it's also much more diffuse,
much more spread out.
And so it does show that actually even things where globe globular clusters,
where everyone sort of thinks they're more all more or less the same,
they really can be very different from each other.
Oh, you say they're very close on the sky, but you've,
you've used two different images to image them. They're not so close.
They will appear in one image.
No, I think there were about a degree or so apart,
a couple of degrees apart on the field of you,
of the telescopes only about half a degree. So you had to move the telescope,
but not really, not very far.
They really are right next to each other in the sky.
Just looking at the dates, you imaged these on the same day as well. Yeah.
Yeah. So once I'd done one, it was no trouble at all to go to the other one.
They were right next to each other. And I think,
I think the exposure times are the same as well.
So it really is kind of a fair comparison between them.
Next. We have M 51, this is a, this is a real, a showboat galaxy. This one.
Okay. Yeah. And 51. Yeah. Everyone's favorite galaxy.
It's probably was one of the early things that I looked at just because it's
such a pushy galaxy it's Gloria spiral structure, the Whirlpool galaxy,
as it's otherwise known, being stirred by its companion.
So that little companion that sort of tightly stirring things around absolutely
beautiful galaxy to look at.
And I was really pleased when I was able to get a decent picture of it.
To the naked eye. Is it even a V is anything visible?
It's not even a speck as a, it's just, this is nothing to the naked eye.
I think it's too faint. Yeah. I think the only galaxy largest galaxy,
a decent distance away you can see with the naked eye is the Andromeda galaxy M
31. Um, so this one you really need to telescope to see.
That's not a bad image,
that one that's starting to get up around kind of what I would, you know,
semiprofessional quality until you compare it to a proper professional M 51.
That's the thing. I mean, you know, I'm, I'm really pleased with these pictures,
but actually the people who do this stuff properly and, you know, do the,
so the telescope I'm using has a little color detector in it. So actually it's,
you know, you get your, your whole color picture all in one, go,
the people who do the job more properly,
take pictures through different colored filters and then combine them and do use
all sorts of fancy software to really extract the maximum from their data.
I'm doing the easy thing of just having the telescope,
bring it all together for me and make a quick color picture. But yeah,
I'm pretty chuffed with them.
It's funny, isn't it. Even though you've done as little as almost,
you could possibly humanly have done to claim to made the image,
you didn't even align the telescope. Uh,
there's something about knowing it's yours.
It really is. It is bizarre. Yes. And you know, all credit to the technology.
It did most of the hard work, but I'm still claiming it as mine.
All right. M 63, we've got another galaxy.
I image this one just because it's of a nice contrast to M 51 in that it is
another spiral galaxy. It's really rather a pretty spiral galaxy,
but completely different in character in the [inaudible] is one of these things
called a grand design spiral. Uh, N 63 a is a,
what's known as a flocculant spiral galaxy. So cool.
Because it looks sort of wooly, it looks like little Tufts of wool.
It's clearly sort of completely different in appearance 251.
And so there's been an interesting point of contention in astronomy as to what,
what it is that causes different types of spiral structure.
And it seems likely that this sort of flocculent spiral structure probably has a
rather different origin from the grand design that we saw in messier 51.
Okay. How have we done M 63 on deep sky videos? Yes. It was our most recent one.
Yeah. And in fact, you've put this image in it, this images in your video.
So yes, I was just looking,
I was looking at the website saying it's not there and that's because we've done
it so recently I haven't put it on the website yet.
So, and in fact, part of the,
part of the reason I took the picture was because I knew you were making a video
and I thought I might be able to sneak it into the video,
the sunflower galaxy sunflower galaxy.
Cause it looks like those little fine pedals you find in a sunflower yeah.
NGC 42 44. So this isn't in the messier catalog,
but it's in the new general catalog.
Yeah.
And you can see it's not as big and impressive and bright as the things in the
messier catalog,
which is why it didn't make it into the messier catalog because they really had
to be things that you could find relatively easily, um,
or other messier or one of his collaborators could find relatively easily.
But actually part of the reason why it's not so big and bright is because it's
exactly Adrian, it's a beautiful disc Aloxi that we're looking at sideways on.
And so it doesn't look as impressive because you only get that sort of sideways,
thin view of it.
But at some level it is in a very impressive thing to look at because it shows
quite how thin spiral galaxies really are,
how when you do get to see the major on, they really are dislike. Um,
so this is a sort of a,
some of the first evidence that the was that as to what the three-dimensional
structure of galaxies really was that the fact that you occasionally saw them
this thin meant that they had to be really intrinsically very thin discs of
stars. Next.
We have, I see three, four to what's. I see, I don't know that one.
So I see is the index catalog. There's the messier catalog.
Then there was the new general catalog came along with a much bigger catalog of
star clusters, Nebula and galaxies. Um,
and then as a sort of supplement to the new general catalog,
the NGC was this thing called the IC, the index catalog,
which essentially sort of hoovered up a lot of objects that hadn't been found
for the NGC. They tend to be smaller and fainter,
which is why they weren't in the NGC.
And a lot of them were actually only fire found when photography started coming
into astronomy and people could actually,
instead of having to observe just with the eye to an IP,
could actually take pictures and see things that have been too faint to see
before. And so this particular galaxy, for example,
wasn't found until the 1890s, um, which is surprising because it's actually,
it's a big galaxy is a big bright galaxy intrinsically.
It's almost the same size as the full moon.
So it would be a big galaxy on the sky, but it's very, very fine.
And the reason it's very fine is because it's very close to the plane of the
Milky way.
It's only about 10 degrees out of the plane of the Milky way and the Milky way
contains all this city stuff that absorbs light.
So that w we're sort of viewing it through all this obscuration,
that's associated with the dust,
the city material in the plane of the Milky way.
And so only about a quarter of its light actually gets through,
we lose three quarters of the light from it, which is why it looks so pathetic.
And ghost-like in those images is also why there's so many stars in the images
because we're very close to the plane of the Milky way.
So we're starting to pick up more and more of the Milky way stars.
And so the reason why it ends up looking so sort of pathetically faint is
because we're viewing it through all this fog of the interstellar dust within
the Milky way, which is sort of making it lose most of the light.
And so we only see this sort of wrecked like appearance of a galaxy.
I think, I mean, my impression, my initial impression, which of course,
you know, after thinking for a few seconds, I realized was ridiculous,
but because it's so faint and because there were so many stars and it almost
creates this illusion that we're seeing through it,
and we're seeing stars on the other side of it.
But of course all the stars you see that are individual stars are well and truly
in the foreground.
Very definitely. Yeah. Yeah.
And actually part of the interesting thing is that we're not really seeing
through things at all, right. The reason why things appear,
so find is we're not seeing through the Milky way. And so,
although we tend to think of galaxies as transparent,
that you can see things behind them.
This is telling us that that's not quite the whole story.
That actually there is quite a lot of obscuration and the galaxy,
which prevents you from seeing things behind them.
We're almost lucky the earth is as far flung as it is.
The good news is that the dust in the Milky way is in a pretty thin plane,
which means that the number of directions where we ended up looking through a
lot of it is, is not very many, right? Cause most directions you could look in,
you're kind of looking out through it.
And so you're not looking through much of it.
You have to be pretty unlucky to be looking right in the plane of the galaxy.
So, so it doesn't mean there were lots of directions we could look in,
but there are some places where you really can't see very much just because the
obscuration is that, that intense.
That obscuring dust that is sits along the plane of the Milky
way. How far out does it reach from the center? Like, are we in it?
Are we sitting in that dust or does it get more diffuse out as you get further
out into the disk? So it does.
Get more diffused. There is still some there,
basically wherever there are stars, you end up with dust because of the star,
the dust comes from star.
Some of the late stages of stellar burning are kind of not,
they're not smokeless effectively.
So they just put out lots of this sorting material.
And so actually wherever there are stars, you'll end up finding dust.
So stars are big polluters for all this talk about how clean solar energy is.
They really are well, most of their lives they're pretty well behaved.
But as I say,
in some of those later stages where they're sort of throwing off a lot of their
outer layers of gas and cooling down a lot,
that's where you tend to get dust grains forming. So in those late stages,
you end up throwing a lot of dust out into the galaxy.
Okay, next we have NGC four, four, four, nine.
Yeah. I mean, this is no particular favorite galaxy.
I took a picture of it cause it's one that I happened to have written a paper
about all. He's been one of the authors on a paper about this galaxy.
It's a splotchy looking galaxy thing called an irregular galaxy.
It's a pushy close cousin to the large Magellanic cloud.
So those from the Southern hemisphere,
very familiar with the large Magellanic cloud is one of the galaxies you can see
with the naked eye is pretty similar to it in that like the large Magellanic
cloud, it has a bar like structure in it. It's a disc Aloxi,
but it's very messy. It's not as tidy as the spiral galaxies.
It's quite a bit further away. So it's quite a lot harder to see,
but the interesting difference between it and the large Magellanic cloud is it
that this galaxy is producing an awful lot of stars.
It's almost a Starburst galaxy.
It's producing an intense burst of stars right now, or at least in the,
in the recent past. Um,
one of the unanswered questions until a couple of years ago was why,
why is this galaxy producing stars so vigorously and what we were able to do
by taking a really deep image? So this was, uh,
an 18 hour exposure with a half meter telescope.
So still by astronomical standards of relatively small telescope half,
we did telescope as a smallish telescope.
But by looking at this patch of sky for 18 hours,
we've got a very deep image and we're able to see that this galaxy actually has
a companion that it's ripped to pieces.
So it's clearly had a close encounter with an even smaller galaxy.
This is quite a small galaxies to start with,
but it's had a close encounter with an even smaller galaxy.
And the net effect of that is it ended up ripping the other galaxy to pieces,
but also triggering a big burst of star formation in this galaxy.
What was it like imaging this one,
like for old time's sake and because of a personal connection and seeing this
splodge like all the other ones, but,
but having all this extra knowledge about it,
and now this like this relationship that you form under the fire of writing a
paper about it.
So that was really nice,
but actually the other interesting thing and the sort of the warm glow I got
from looking at this one is most of the other galaxies I've looked at are very
sort of they're the standard galaxies that everyone looks at. Right?
And so actually there were lots and lots of images of them at some level,
my images don't really stack up to the beautiful ones that some people end up
making. And I don't feel like I'm doing anything. You know,
lots of people have trodden that path before.
The nice thing about these galaxies is not that many people bother to look at
it. And so it's nice to look at a galaxy, which is, you know, is,
is one of those in one of those little nooks and crannies that most people don't
bother to in astronomy Fairlight, you've got off the beaten track a bit. Yeah,
absolutely. And as you said,
it's kind of nice to look at a galaxy where I think I, you know,
I know something interesting about this galaxy.
And so do you do feel that sort of connection to it as well? Yeah. Last year.
But not least Virgo cluster M 87 and NGC four
double five zero.
So yeah,
so our nearest sort of brightest cluster of galaxies is one which I can just
about get to through a gap in the trees.
So I had to go at looking at it and it's big enough on the sky that you don't
get to see the whole cluster at once,
but you can start picking out some of the galaxies from it.
And so one of the really famous galaxies in this cluster is MSCI 80, 87 and 87.
It's sort of right near the middle of the cluster is a big, bright galaxy.
What it's most famous for at the moment is that it's where that image,
the first image of a black hole came from the black hole telescope,
took an image of it. And actually you can just about,
see one of the consequences of that black hole in this image is quite hard to
pick out. Um, but if you look at about sort of two o'clock in that image,
there's a sort of little bit of an extension in the light.
It's not quite round and what you're picking out there is a hint of the jet.
So there's a Jetta material being flung out from that black hole,
the immediate vicinity of that black hole and in a very well collimated way.
And so M 87 famously has his jet. It's actually quite hard to see.
So I was really pleased when even with this little four and a half inch
telescope,
you could actually start seeing some hints of the jet coming out of the middle
of med seven.
Yeah.
It's almost like that's an eyeball and that's where like the front of the eye is
or something. Yeah.
It just looks that little bit distorted. Doesn't it?
You can just see that it's not quite round there's something going on in that
direction.
And that really is just a hint of that Jetta material getting flung out.
And NGC four double five, zero is also there. You included that.
That's another one that I hadn't to have a little bit of a personal connection
to it doesn't look like a particularly exciting galaxy.
It's one of these as zero galaxy. So it's a disc Aloxi,
but without much by way of spiral structure or anything,
it's pretty much edge on what it's famous for is that in the 1990s, Vera Rubin,
uh, took a look at it, studied the lights,
split the light from this galaxy up into spectra and found by studying the
Doppler shifts in the light from that spectra that this galaxy is a bit strange
in that it's not rotating either clockwise or anti-clockwise,
it's actually got half the stars going around one way and half the stars going
around the other way. So it's a real oddity somehow this galaxy formed with,
with the stars going around in this sort of two directions at the same time.
And there were lots of ideas and theories about how it might've formed than
there were some people were saying, well,
maybe the two discs form simultaneously. And they do look pretty much identical,
certainly from the analysis that Vera Rubin and her collaborators did.
They said that they look pretty much the same as each other.
The N the bit that we were able to add is that a few years ago with rather
better data, 10, 15 years later, that we could get,
we were able to show that actually by studying the light in great detail,
the two sets of stars are not the same one is quite a bit younger than the
other. So actually what happened is one this form rotating one way,
then the whole load of gas fell in rotating the other way and formed another
disc of stars going around the other way. So this.
Uh, this period of backyard astronomy you've been doing, uh,
do you think it's been good for you? Like, has it, has it, has it,
has it like changed the way you think in any way as a professional astronomer?
Or is it just something you did or like, what are you,
what are you taking from it.
I'm enjoying it fundamentally. No,
and it's hard enough at the moment to find things to enjoy, right?
So it's actually nice to have something new to try out, play around with,
to enjoy doing so I've enjoyed taking the pictures and thinking about them a bit
and talking about them and, you know,
I'd be putting them out on Twitter and chatting about them.
So it's an opportunity for better outreach in astronomy. And it's just,
you know, at some level it is nice to actually, you know,
instead of just looking at the pretty pictures that the Hubble space telescope
taken, you know,
it's nice to look at your own pictures and then net New York and that as good as
they were supposed to tell us those pictures,
but that's okay because I made them. And it's just,
you do get a definite sense of satisfaction. Just making the pictures, yourself.
Good sales, Mike. I want one of those telescopes now I bought,
I bought a manual one a few years ago and I never saw a single thing through it.
Cause I just couldn't line it up. I'll get it to work.
And I just put it in storage after a few frustrated nights. So.
That, that's why I've never bought a telescope like that.
I know I would have done exactly the same thing. Right.
All right. Well, thanks for your time. My pleasure.
I look forward to more pictures. I look forward to taking them.
I'll follow you on Twitter to make sure I see them all.
Mike, the sun. Can you see your video picture or not?
Because the sun's coming to a point where it's half on your face and half night
you got a towel. Sorry, a towel. All right.
We can do.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah. If it doesn't fall down on your head, halfway through the recording. Yeah.
I don't think the sun's going to get into a position, which makes it bad again.
It's a nice soft light now. Very well done.
Okay. So let me just set myself up roughly where I was before.
This is lockdown a YouTube and people. Yeah, absolutely.